>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mark Dimunation: Welcome
everybody to another Thursday at 3.
Many of you are familiar faces
now; some of you are new.
Today it's a great pleasure
to welcome Chet Van Duzer
back to our division.
He's a familiar fellow to many
of us here in the library.
We were trying to remember
when he first started showing
up at the reading room.
I think it was around 2010.
In 2011, he was the Kislak Fellow in
the Kluge Center doing work on maps
and the benefit, of course, for
those of us who are in reading rooms
and reference stations when
Chet is around is a simply query
for a book turns into a
small workshop from Chet.
So we've learned a great deal
and he's not only a great scholar
but also a natural teacher and many
of us appreciate that opportunity.
So over the years we've
managed to become equally expert
in the books that he's written.
Floating Island: A
Global Bibliography,
a book on Schoner's 1515 Globe.
A lovely book on the
1507 and 1516 Ptolemy map
and just a few years ago we heard
a talk from him about Sea Monsters
in Medieval and Renaissance Maps.
A book that many of us have on our
shelves actually at the moment.
So today he's talking about
some of his recent work.
Chet's work is always seemed to be
involved around what maps tell us
in terms of understanding
the perception of the world
that surrounds people both the known
and the unknown world and oftentimes
in a very kind of humane
way he's looking at maps
to understand people's
perceptions of the world.
My notion of his talk today which
is about looking at several copies
of Ptolemy's Geography, although
I don't know what was wrong
with just looking at ours.
[Laughter] Has led him to
some conclusions that, again,
has arrived at some
kind of impression
of what these contributors, these
annotators to the geography have
to tell us about the perception of
the world both known and unknown.
So, we're really thrilled to have
you back and to give your talk.
So please welcome Chet Van Duzer.
[ Applause ]
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well, thank you,
Mark, and thank you all for coming.
I don't think I need to say
that manuscript annotations,
notes made by the readers and users
of early modern books
are wonderful evidence
as to how those works
were received and used.
So I'll be looking today at the
annotations in 4 different copies
of Ptolemy's Geography to here
at the Library of Congress
and to other institutions.
[Laughter] So I'll
begin by a few words
about what Ptolemy's Geography is.
It was written in the Second
Century AD in Alexandria, Egypt,
which was then culturally Greek.
It consists of 2 principle parts;
instructions on how to make maps
and a database of about
8,000 placenames
with their latitudes and longitudes.
So the information
needed to fill the maps.
We don't necessarily see
a Ptolemaic map everyday
so here's a Ptolemaic
world map, manuscript,
and just to orient ourselves
a little bit here is Europe,
Africa and Asia.
So when Ptolemy's Geography
was rediscovered in Byzantium
in about 1300 and then
diffused from Byzantium to Italy
and then reproduced in a profusion
of manuscripts and printed editions,
it was realized that Ptolemy's
data was at that point more
than a thousand years old.
And so while on the one hand there
was this great respect for Ptolemy
and his geography, but on the
other hand there was this series
of various different
attempts to supplement
or update or correct Ptolemy.
And just to look at one example
of that, a visual example.
So on this Ptolemaic world
map, the northern edge
of the map is what the
edge of a map should be.
It's the limit of knowledge, but
there are other Ptolemaic world maps
where that is not the case.
Here the geography spills
over the northern border.
So this is one visual example of
the way in which cartographers
and editors of the
work sought to update
and supplement Ptolemy's Geography.
And I would like to consider
the annotations as another way
in which readers and users
of the book supplemented
Ptolemy's Geography in particular
as I said Ptolemy's Geography
is mostly this huge database
of 8,000 placenames with their
latitudes and longitudes.
He offers very little in the
way of description and a lot
of readers felt that want.
They wanted more in
the way of description.
In studying the annotations
in Ptolemy's Geography,
one gets the sense that a desire
for more descriptive information
about the world was an important
motivating factor in the placement,
the writing of annotations
in the book.
So these are the 4 copies I'll look.
One at the Lilly Library, 2
here at the Library of Congress
and the last one at Princeton.
So beginning with the
Lilly Library copy.
I begin not with the Lilly
Library copy but with a,
the map of the British
Isles from the 1513 edition,
which it's the same edition but
that's not the Lilly Library,
but without any annotations,
without any hand coloring
and without any other
graphic editions
which we'll see in a moment.
Switching now to the same map
in the Lilly Library copy,
we can see that first of all it's
hand colored; that's not so unusual.
There is also the addition of 2
ships, which is unusual in the sort
of supplementary decoration
of Ptolemy maps.
And a fairly extensive
program of annotation.
And I'll look at this one annotation
which is just north of Ireland.
Here it is.
I've transcribed the text below
and the annotator is talking
about the conversion of the
British Isles to Christianity.
And you'll notice at the end he
specifies the latitude and longitude
of the middle of this region
and at the very end he
says secundum Schoner.
So very helpfully indicating
the source
that isn't often the
case with annotations.
By Schoner he means Johann
Schoner who was the creator
of this printed globe of 1515.
He also made a manuscript globe
in 1520, which is in the National,
German National Museum in Nuremberg.
To accompany his globe
Schoner printed this pamphlet
which in an interesting way
is similar to the annotations
that occur in copies
of Ptolemy's Geography.
Supplementary information,
descriptive information
that he did not have
room for on the globe.
And it turns out that the annotator
in the Lilly Library
told me was cribbing,
was copying his information
from this pamphlet.
So he found a source that offered
precisely the supplementary
descriptive information he wanted
and copied that information
into this copy of Ptolemy making
it a more complete reference work
if you will to the world.
So here's the passage in question.
I've transcribed the 2.
The wording is not identical
but it's very similar.
In particular at the very end,
it's skipping over the Latin
and you can see that the coordinates
indicated are the same 7 degrees,
30 and 57 degrees.
To look at another example
this is the third map of Africa
in the 1513 Ptolemy
at the Lilly Library.
The annotations are faint but
they're 4 of them on this map,
and I'll focus on this
one here at the bottom.
Here is the transcription.
He's talking about the location
of 2 people in Africa with respect
to the Red Sea and the fact that the
people called fish eaters eat fish.
One helpful thing about
identifying the source
that an annotator was using
is that it can be helpful
in this case filling
information that's been cropped.
So the book was rebound at some
point, information was cropped,
and I was able to supply missing
words because I knew the source
that the annotator was using.
So here's the passage
in Schoner's pamphlet
and here is a comparison
between the 2 texts.
An interesting feature here is that
the coordinates are not the same,
and I think what's happened is
that Schoner was supplying
the coordinates of the center
of the whole region
and the annotator is supplying
the coordinates of the center
of the area where those
2 people live.
That's my best guess.
So in that case, the scheme
of annotation is pretty
simple to understand.
The annotator found a reference work
that contained supplementary
descriptive information
that was to his liking.
He copied some of that
information into the book.
Let's look now at the 1513 Ptolemy
in the Thacher Collection here
at the Library of Congress.
Here's the title page.
In this case, a later
user has scratched
out the name of an earlier owner.
Here is Book 2 Chapters
10 to 11 in that copy.
There's an extensive program
indicating the modern equivalence
of classical placenames and
there is also the addition
of descriptive texts such as
the one I've highlighted here,
and it is at the very
beginning of Chapter 11
of Book 2 of the geography.
So zooming in here we have the
text, I transcribe it on the right,
he's talking about the name
of Germany and the names
of different peoples
that live in Germany.
The source of these
annotations is the 1535 edition
of Ptolemy's Geography.
So, the desire for additional
descriptive information
in Ptolemy's Geography
was not confined
to Ptolemy's Geography was not
confined to manuscript annotations.
People editing the work
and making printed editions
of it also added supplementary
descriptive information.
The 1535 edition has
supplementary material
by Michael Servetus,
the Spanish polymath.
So if we look at the corresponding
passage in the 1535 edition,
that is Book 2 Chapters 10 to
11, again right at the beginning
of Chapter 11 we have supplementary
marginal information that's been
added by Servetus that is not
information that comes from Ptolemy,
and it's precisely
the same information.
He's talking about the
name Germany and the names
of the peoples that live in Germany.
To look at another example at the
beginning of Book 7, Chapter 1 in,
again, the 1511 copy
here at the Library
of Congress, here is the annotation.
He's talking about the River Ganges
and once again he's
taking this information
from the 1535 Ptolemy again
right at the beginning of Book 7,
Chapter 1 in the 1535 edition
we have this printed marginal
information, which is also
about the River Ganges.
It's almost exactly the same
word for word as the annotation
in the 1511 copy of the
Geography here at the library.
So once again we've had the
annotators found a printed book
that contains exactly the type
of descriptive information he
was interested in and he's added
that information to
the book by hand.
Moving on to another case this is
the 1486 Ptolemy here at the Library
of Congress and also in
the Thacher Collection.
Here is the opening of the book.
So it's hand colored.
And here is the 10th map of
Greece, 10th map of Europe,
which is of Greece, and we can
see a fairly extensive program
of annotation not so different from
what we've seen before but, in fact,
the program in this book is much
more extensive as we can see here
so very extensive notes added
at the bottom of both pages.
These being the pages following
the fourth map of Africa
and following some maps is
the entire page is filled
with supplementary
descriptive information.
So to look at one example here
we have the first map of Europe,
which is the British Isles and
zooming in on the annotation
and translating in the Year
180 after the birth of Christ,
the King of Britain, named
Lucius, converted to Christianity.
The island was later called
Anglia because it was conquered
by the Anglos although at the
time there were already Christians
in Spain and France but not all
of Spain or France was Christian
like England was called a wholly
Christian country and the flamines,
the priests of the Roman
religion, converted to bishops
and the archflamines
into archbishops.
This was when Eleuterus was Pope
in Rome and Commodus Antonius,
son of Marcus Aurelius, was emperor.
So a type of information
very different from a catalog
of placenames with their
latitudes and longitudes.
More detailed descriptive
historical information.
In particular here relating to
Christian history and the spread
of Christianity in Europe.
So this particular book has a very
extensive program of annotation,
and I'll just indicate some of
the annotator's favorite subjects.
So Christian history,
unsurprisingly, Alexander the Great.
Many of the annotations
relate to Alexander the Great
as a mythological figure.
The Seven Wonder of the World,
information about the wonders have
spreads throughout the annotations.
And spices, a pretty substantial
discourse on the spices of Asia.
So looking at one other
specific annotation
in this book this is a page
following the third map of Africa
and reading the text at
the top Pindar the Theban
who flourished during
the first Olympiad said
that water exceeds the
other elements just
as gold exceeds the other metals
because you can barely remove
something without the help of water
as it is known by the
various virtues it has
in different parts of the world.
Athenaeums says that the waters
of the Nile are extremely fertile
and Pliny, Galen and Seneca
say that women even come
to bear children every 7 years by
virtue of the waters of the Nile
which make them fertile for which
reason the poet parmenon calls the
Nile the God of Egypt, which is well
known for Juan de Pineda in his book
On Christian Agriculture.
So here again the annotator is
very conveniently indicating one
of his sources which is this
book Juan de Pineda's Agricultura
Christiana, which was
published in Salamanca in 1589.
What that tells us is that
the annotations were made
about 100 years after
the book was printed.
They were also made in Spanish
rather than Latin, which is unusual,
but I think the fact that
they were made 100 years
after the book was published
is really impressive.
It's a real testament to
the continuing interest
in Ptolemy's Geography
even as, for example,
other cartographic
material became available
such as Abraham Ortelius' Theatrum
Orbis Terrarum, the first atlas
in the modern sense of the word
which was first published in 1570.
It's also perhaps evidence
of the expense of a copy
of Ptolemy's Geography given that
it was seen to make more sense
to add material to a copy that
was a 100 years old rather
than buying a new one.
Another page of annotation
in the same book it has extensive
supplementary material about China
and the Philippines but
interestingly nothing
about the New World appears in
the annotations in this copy.
Moving now to the fourth example,
which is the 1525 Ptolemy
at Princeton.
Here is the Ptolemaic map of Spain.
You can see that there are
annotations almost everywhere.
It really is an extraordinary degree
of annotation and I think it's fair
to say the annotations are
of an extraordinarily
high level of interest.
Here's the Ptolemaic
world map that we can see.
I'll come back to this later,
but this is very careful layout
of the annotations on the page.
And as in the Thacher 1486 copy
at the Library of Congress,
we have extensive supplementary
material added
to blank pages following the maps.
The copy again was printed in 1525,
the annotations were
composed in 1527.
At one point the annotator speaks
of a historical event in Hungary
which took place in 1526 as having
taken place the previous summer.
So it's nice to be able to date
the composition of the annotations.
We can see this difference,
visual difference
in the 2 halves of the book.
So we have the text block of
Ptolemy's Geography on the left
and the maps on the right.
The maps are annotated, the text
is not and it was quite clear
that a dealer at some point
in the book's history put these
2 halves together in order
to be able to sell a complete copy.
I'll return to that question
at the end of the talk.
So the content of the annotations
in the Princeton 1525 Ptolemy.
So just to take a few examples
this is the third map of Africa.
Again we can see this very, very
extensive program of annotation.
I'll look at 3 spots
beginning with this one.
The annotator says add and that's
instruction to a student telling him
to write in the book add that the
map above is defective for there
where I put this sign,
which I have circled,
there is Aphroditopolites nome and a
land-locked metropolis between which
and Crocodilopolis towards
the Nile there was Lake Mirios
about which below.
So he uses a sign to indicate where
on the map this information applies
to and then he also indicates
he'll add more information
about this lake below.
So there is the sign
he's added to the map
and the relevant location just above
Crocodilopolis and then continuing
with the text below
and this is quite long.
Add, again, an instruction
to the student, write this.
Add beside Crocodilopolis the fact
that its king built a labyrinth
towards that city of Psanietum
in which there were 6,000 homes
and the pyramids along its sides
were more worthy of admiration
than the temple of Diana in Ephesus.
Nor was Like Mirios, above
which the labyrinth was located,
and which was created by men, any
less remarkable being 3,600 stadia
in circumference stretching north
and south and 50 paces deep.
In the middle of it, there were 2
pyramids that rose 50 paces high
out of the water and extended
just as far into the depths.
A pace of 6 feet or 4 cubits
while a foot is sixteen fingers.
So adding information
about units of measurement.
The lake was filled by six months
of diverting water from the Nile
and this is enough to
show the useless vanity
of the Egyptian kings.
[Laughter] So, this annotator
has quite a strong character.
The 1525 edition already contains
supplementary descriptive material
and he is very comfortable
disagreeing with that material
and saying that the person who
composed that material is a fool
and in a general way we'd see
he's adding a lot of historical
and descriptive information
here exactly the sort of thing
that is not found in
Ptolemy and I think one
of the other really outstanding
features of this book is
that the annotations were
composed for a student.
So this is a program of geographical
education in the early 16th Century.
Look at another example,
the fourth map of Asia.
He writes not far from Tripoli there
is a field that Strabo calls Macra
in which Posidonius says
a dead dragon was seen.
It covered half an acre and was so
thick that men mounted on horses
on either side could
not see each other.
Its mouth was large enough to
receive a man riding a horse
and each scale of its skin
was larger than a shield.
So, we'll see that the
annotator is interested
in natural history information,
geographical information
and ethnographical information.
Another example from
Ptolemaic map of Greece.
Here he's drawn in 2
islands that Ptolemy omitted
and writes Ptolemy omits this island
which is famous for
the grave of Homer.
So a couple of things here
despite his great respect
for Ptolemy he's very content to
disagree with him and correct him
and also his powerful
interest in classical culture.
So, the vast majority of
his annotations relate
to classical culture and not
so much to Christian history.
The map of the Atlantic
and the New World.
So that's South America
at the lower left.
Going back 1 page to the
page preceding the map
of the New World he has a
substantial annotation here
that says remark as I often said
that neither this route to the west
that is to the New World nor that
of the Portuguese around the top
of Africa is new but had already
been done by other ancients,
then abandoned and now finally in
our times taken up again as is clear
from Aristotle a most celebrated
witness and a noble author
for increasing one's confidence.
So, his respect for classical
antiquity was so strong
that he believed that the New
World had already been discovered
in antiquity and he's also referring
to passages circumnavigating Africa
that were made in antiquity.
So the recent voyages and
discoveries of the Spanish
and Portuguese were in his
mind worth very little.
[Laughter] Looking at the map
of the New World he writes here
along these same lines we will
venture based on the excerpts from
Aristotle that I transcribed below
that the men and women found in
this new land were Carthaginians
by origin and that afterwards left
alone and deprived of communication
with other peoples
they became savages
and gradually lost their
customs and rites and the use
of clothing through long desuetude.
So he's referring to a passage
in the pseudo Aristotelian work
that says that the Carthaginians
discovered a very, very large island
in the Atlantic with navigatable
rivers and he believes that that's
where the people of the
New World came from.
So this is a great intellectual
question if all people descend
from Adam and Eve and Columbus
was the first encounter
with the New World where did the
people who were there come from?
This is his answer to that question.
He believes it was the
Carthiagian voyage alluded
to by pseudo Aristotle.
So, moving on to some evidence
of the annotators shall
we say sharp character.
Here we have the modern
map of France.
He's added this banner
across the top
and he does this on
a number of maps.
And he says this province produces
a great number of chicken farmers,
innkeepers, cooks, flute players,
gamblers, drunkards and fools.
[Laughter] So he has his sharp
opinions about a number of people.
As I'll indicate later, he's Italian
but he has unlimited scorn
for Southern Italians.
[Laughter] The modern map of Spain.
Here he says the best thing for
one's financial affairs is not
to take a loan from
a Catalan merchant.
[Laughter] The book has
quite a number of these,
of statements like this and it's
pretty outrageous statements.
And so again he's not afraid to make
blanket criticisms of whole nations,
he's not afraid to disagree with
Ptolemy, he's not afraid to disagree
with previous commentators
on Ptolemy.
So, it's interesting to look
at which maps are annotated
and which maps are not because
they're not all annotated and what,
it raises the question of whether
this program was perhaps incomplete.
Whether he intended eventually
to annotate all the maps
and didn't have time but
nonetheless some of them
in their current state
are not annotated.
So here we have the Ptolemaic map
of Taprobana in the Indian Ocean,
which is usually identified
with Sri Lanka.
He certainly, there's plenty
of classical material he could
have sited about Taprobana.
He did not.
I'm inclined to suspect that
that's because his focus really was
on the Mediterranean Basin and
where classical civilization was
most active.
The modern map of the Holy Land.
It's a little surprising that
there's no annotation on this map.
The modern map of Southern Africa.
I think a lot of other annotators
might have eagerly written something
on this map about the
Portuguese voyages
around circumnavigating Africa.
Since he believed that this
had already been accomplished
in antiquity his lack of remark
here I think is understandable.
So looking at the sources
of the annotations,
one of his favorite
works was this one,
Rhodiginus's Antiquarum Lectionum
which is this huge collection
of notes on mostly
classical subjects,
but some modern themes as well.
The sheer amount of
information is encyclopedic.
Fortunately there's an index
because without an index it
would be almost unnavigatable,
but it is a tremendously
rich resource in terms
of if one were somehow
interested in acquiring information
from classical sources without
going to the sources themselves,
this is a wonderful work for that.
The annotator does also cite
classical sources directly
so I guess in this, when he used
this book, he was saving time.
This is a similar work by Sabelico,
Rapsodie historiarum Enneadum
first published in 1516.
Again a tremendous mass of material
called from classical sources.
This is Pomponius Mela's the Roman
geographers study of the world
with the commentary of
Vadianus, the Swiss humanist,
and he makes very heavy use
of Vadianus's commentary.
This book is on display here.
And the title page of
Giovanni's Pontano's Dialogi.
A lot of the insults that he makes
of various people's
come from this book.
So he wasn't just using phrases
he had heard on the street.
He's a humanist.
He has a source for his insults.
[Laughter] And a few words about
the care spent on the annotations.
So here we have the
detailed annotations.
If you've looked at
annotated Ptolemy's,
one thing that is immediately
striking is that it's legible.
So a scribe was paid to write
these annotations into this book.
So immediately we're talking
about set aside all the time
spent perusing these works
to choose the information
to put into the book.
On top of that, we have the
money spent on a scribe.
So we're talking about a
very elite circle here.
Just for comparison
sake here's the sort
of handwriting you often
see in an annotated Ptolemy.
Yeah, sort of scribbling.
Here's a modern map of Eastern
India and the text following it.
Again, this profusion of information
added to the book and one
of the interesting features is how
carefully planned the whole program
of annotations is.
He often refers in one
annotation to another one.
So zooming in a bit he says
in addition to what was said
on the four other maps of India,
I think it is worth adding a few
words here regarding the fertility
of that land.
So he's always very conscious
of what he's written elsewhere.
The Ptolemy map of the world,
which I showed earlier.
The layout here is
really remarkable.
So symmetrically at the top and
bottom of a page we have quotations
from Vitruvius about the
inhabitants about the northern
and southern parts of the world.
So, symmetric quotations
from the same author
and we have these triangular texts,
you know, and it didn't happen
by accident that the texts fits
perfectly in those triangles.
This whole thing had to have been
tried out before and he argues
in these texts that the inhabited
lands form an effective large island
surrounded by the ocean.
So he has a title of the annotation
at the left on the Hyperboreans,
at the right on the Antipodes.
And those texts go down the
margins and then stretch
in toward the gutter and they're
stretching towards the gutter
exactly the same amount.
So the whole layout
of the annotations
on this map is very
carefully planned.
The purpose of the annotation.
So as I said, these were
annotations made for a student.
In the third map of Africa
looking at the lower left
where I added the Nasamones
who were missing
so that you would know
the custom of this people.
So you, addressing the student,
and we see here this interest
in ethnography and,
again, correcting Ptolemy.
They were missing.
Here I am I'm adding them.
The Ptolemaic map of Greece.
The lower left this I have willingly
written so that you will know
that these provinces have many
products suited to the study
of the inhabitants that is things
that are revealing
about the inhabitants.
So, again, a strong
interest in ethnography.
Following the Ptolemaic
map of France.
Anyone investigating
the ancient customs
of the French should be aware
that and so on and so forth.
So there's an expectation that one
who is reading these annotations
would be interested in knowing
about the ancient customs
of the French.
The eighth map of Europe about
which also see Book 1 of our Strabo,
to whom you should have recourse for
such things rather than to others.
So advice to the student
about which classical authors
to consult on which subjects.
Ptolemaic map of Asia Minor.
I've explained these things from
Alexander the Great here so that
by using them you can
understand what Pliny says
in Book 5, Chapter 29.
So this expectation that the
student will be constantly engaged
with classical authors.
All the Alpine peoples are listed
by Pliny but you, the student,
list them with their modern names.
Write their modern names beside
the ancient ones by conjecture.
So he's giving an exercise
to the student write
out the classical place
names and try to figure
out what the modern equivalents are.
This is the clearest example, the
clearest evidence that this was
for a student, that this
was part of an education.
So how does this program of
geographical education compare
with others that were available
in the early 16th Century?
The short answer it's far,
far more sophisticated.
It was in the early 16th Century
that works, that educational works
in geography began to be published
really and they're incredibly basic.
So here's Peter Apian's
Cosmographicus liber of 1524.
Very close in time
to the annotations
in the Princeton Ptolemy.
Asia is described in one page.
He probably has one annotation
in Asia that's that long.
A long list of place names
with latitudes and longitudes.
So memorization.
So we're not getting a lot of the
descriptive ethnographic rich detail
that the annotator
provides the student.
Johannes Honter's Rudimenta
cosmographica first published
in 1530.
Just take a sentence at random.
The most important cities
of Poland are, a list.
No actual details given
about any of them.
List of classical names
with modern equivalents.
This at least is something similar
to what he designed his student,
the annotator of the
Princeton Ptolemy.
What can we conclude
about the annotator?
Well, he was Italian.
He uses Italian sources mostly
not exclusively but almost.
He, there's an occasional Italian
word that slips into his Latin
and the banner across one map
of Italy reads [inaudible]
virtuous inherent in Italian blood.
[Laughter] And there's plenty of
other evidence that he was Italian.
I do not know what city he is from.
He never puts a circle around
a city that is suggestive.
He does not say who he is.
It would be certainly
gratifying to know who he was.
It might be helpful in elucidating
some aspects of the program
of annotation, but
overall I find the content
of the annotations more
interesting than his identity.
He tells us that he traveled widely.
He visited the Hungarian court
on commerce, he visited Augsburg.
He traveled to England.
At one point he lists the
most important English
ecclesiastical writers.
He may have visited the
shrine of Thomas Becket.
He has a description of it that is,
that doesn't appear
in any other source.
He also seems to have
traveled to Greece.
Some of the details he gives in
his annotations about the maps,
on the maps of Greece
he's detailed enough
to have been written by
someone who is there.
And his primary interest wasn't
European classical antiquity.
The maps of Asia are
very lightly annotated,
the modern maps are
lightly annotated,
which is a powerful
piece of evidence.
So he's really more
interested in ancient geography.
There was no annotation on
the map of the Holy Land.
He repeated argues against
the great antiquity of Egypt
and this is his way of asserting
the far greater importance
of Greece and Rome.
And, again, he argues that recent
geographical discoveries merely
repeated the accomplishments
of the ancient.
So a few conclusions.
What is this book exactly?
So we know it was intended for
an advanced student of geography.
This is not for a beginner
by any means.
The annotations profess
an interest in ethnography
and more broadly show the
richness of classical geography.
The hiring of a scribe
and careful arrangement
of the text indicate
a luxury production
and so I think the most
natural conclusion is
that this was a textbook if you
will for a very elite student.
So there was a lot of time and money
available for this project and,
again, we're talking about
a student more advanced
than would have been served by the
textbooks available at the time.
It's also at least possible
that this was a fair copy
for the annotator himself.
Hard to be certain.
So as I said before what Princeton
has is really half the book.
They have the annotated maps, which
at some point were put together
with the unannotated
text from another copy.
By remarkable stroke of good
fortune so here's that point
in the Princeton copy
where we have the,
you can see the physical difference.
Between the pages we have the
beginning of the annotated maps
on the right and the
unannotated text on the left.
By remarkable stroke of good
fortune I was able to find
in a private collection in Brussels
just the text, not the maps,
annotated by the same hand.
>> Whoa.
>> Chet Van Duzer: So there is,
I mean the handwriting
is identical and, again,
so what Princeton has is
just the annotated maps,
what the collector has is
just the annotated text.
The collector realized that
it didn't make any sense
for the 2 halves to be apart
and that Princeton would never,
ever, ever sell their half.
[Laughter] So he very
graciously has sold his half
of the book to Princeton.
And so now after while quite some
time apart and at least some time
on different sides of the Atlantic,
they are now reunited,
which is very exciting.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: We have
time for a couple of questions.
I also want to make an announcement
that Chet has volunteered
to find any kind of missing
[inaudible] from our collection
and bring it back to us preferably
by donation if at all possible.
[Laughter] But we do have time
for some questions and, Chet,
if you could describe
what's on the table
so everyone can see afterwards.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Sure.
So we have 3 Ptolemy's here.
We have the 1511 copy on the
left, which has the annotations
that were borrowed from the
1535 edition, which is right.
And I've indicated
with arrows in the copy
on the left a manuscript
annotation which comes
from the printed text indicated
with an arrow on the right.
Then we have the 1486 Ptolemy here
which is the one extensively
annotated in Spanish.
And here we have 2 of the
most important sources used
by the annotator of
the Princeton copy.
By good fortune both of these
copies are insult annotated
and await study.
>> Mark Dimunation:
So questions for Chet?
>> Thank you so much.
This was just fascinating and
I have a question about the,
I believe it was the Princeton
version that you mentioned here.
It's such a colorful annotator here
who seems to have maybe traveled
in Greece and presumably this
is 1525 that he is doing this?
So presumably this is Greece under
Ottoman rule and I'm wondering
if anywhere in the
annotations he says anything
about the origins of the Turks?
Their rule of Constantinople
and the eastern half
of the Ancient Roman Empire?
You know whether he views
them as being destroyers
of civilization antiquity or if he
has a different take on the Turks?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Great question.
He does not anywhere say
any such thing and, yes,
I'm not certain that
he went to Greece.
A few of the things he says
incline me to think that he did,
and I might be willing to think that
he wouldn't mention the Turks just
because his interest was
really in classic antiquity.
I'm not sure.
It seems like that would be
a difficult subject to omit
if one had been to Greece.
>> Thank you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Chet Van Duzer: So the
earliest surviving manuscript
of Ptolemy's Geography that does
have maps dates from about 1300
and it's in the Vatican Library, and
it's not certain but that may be,
so the way Ptolemy's Geography was
rediscovered was that a scholar,
Byzantine scholar Maximus Planudes
found a manuscript of the text
of Ptolemy's Geography,
it did not have maps,
but what is Ptolemy's Geography?
It is instructions
on how to make maps
and the data to fill in those maps.
So he did precisely that,
created a set of maps,
and the Vatican manuscript from
about 1300 may be that manuscript.
If not, it's probably
very closely related to it
but that's the earliest
one that we have.
>> Thank you.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes?
>> I was actually interested
in the decorative elements
and annotations [inaudible]
and wondering
if you knew of a source for that?
[Inaudible] banner who saw
a banner later in the book
and looked somewhat like
that, but I'm most curious.
And do you see that often in
annotations that they're framed
or they look like modelings.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yeah,
it does look like moldings.
I have not seen that elsewhere.
One of the really curious
features of the book is that some
of the annotations have a single
border while some have no border,
some have a single border,
some have a double border
and some have a triple border.
I have not been able to detect any
system for why those are singled
out that way, and I would
love to figure that out.
>> I just had a question.
In some sense particularly the
annotator is kind of blending genres
in the sense that we have a
long established tradition
of chronicles, right?
And you know Ptolemy himself is just
sort of interested in making maps.
So he wants to create this sort of
hybrid genre, and I'm just curious
if you have encountered, because it
looks like we have other examples
of Ptolemy that have
been taken chronicle
like information and
putting in the map.
Do we ever find annotators of
chronicles putting maps, you know,
do you get the reverse ever?
>> Chet Van Duzer: You do sometimes.
Not by annotators that I
can think of, but, you know,
to have a world map and a
chronicle is not unusual.
I can't think of any cases off hand
of an annotator drew
a chronicle and a map.
But one of the interesting
things just to reiterate
about the 1525 Ptolemy this
annotator is the editor had already
added very extensive
descriptive text to the book
and it's interesting that
someone would choose something
that already had such extensive
supplementary information
to add even more.
>> You mentioned Lake Mirios
in Egypt and does such a lake
by any name actually exist?
And if so, what's your theory
as to how this particular
annotator learned about it?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I would
have to look at my notes
to remember whether the
lake actually exist,
but I'm quite that that
information came from the larger
of the two books there, and I have,
in my notes I have the passage.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
There's considerable disagreement
about that but something like 4th
to 5th Century AD if
I recall correctly.
>> Mark Dimunation: We
got time for one more.
>> You mentioned that
the annotations
of the 1525 Ptolemy were
approximately in 1527, right?
And that was based on something
that happened in the year before.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes.
>> Was that about the Turks
attacking the country?
>> Chet Van Duzer: It was, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So that's as close as we get to a
mention of the Turks is something
in Hungary rather than in Greece.
>> Mark Dimunation: The
Battle of Mohawks [phonetic].
>> Yes.
>> Mark Dimunation: So before we
say thank you, we do have materials
out here that we're willing
to show you in a minute
if people can help us push
the benches in and reminder
that the books are out so
that we can show them to you.
There are too many of you to
allow you to actually page
through the books, but we will
be happy to try and help you get
through the materials if we can.
Please, let's give Chet
another round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.